joining me now editor-in-chief of The
Daily wire Ben Shapiro Ben thanks for
joining me and thanks for having me all
right Ben talk to me about this it seems
to me insane that we don't protect our
kids in school the same way that these
celebrities were protected at the Oscars
last night am I wrong
no there's no excuse for that obviously
and and it'sit's never made a lot of
sense to me the folks who are claiming
that there shouldn't be armed security
in schools that the people who are
qualified to to carry firearms and are
capable of defending students shouldn't
be allowed to carry firearms and all of
the gun control talk as you mentioned
last night at the Oscars betrays is it
alive by the fact that they've got a
bunch of armed guards walking around
outside none of the people who are
actually at the Oscars are giving up the
security that I'm sure guards there
they're gated mansions right and there's
some hypocrisy too because these are the
same people who are hashtagging black
lives matter who are standing up for
Colin Kaepernick some of them are even
donating to Colin Kaepernick's funds
here they're claiming that police are
corrupt they're claiming they're
claiming all police officers are racist
that they target black men because of
their skin color yet they actually have
the audacity to say you the American
people should not be allowed to bear
arms you are not qualified to own
firearms or ar-15s but the police let's
leave this to professionals they can we
trust them yeah evil racist terrible
police video moans of guns and president
Trump who we hate and as a Nazi should
be handed those guns as well I mean the
logic here does not hold but I'm not
sure that logic was ever the strong suit
in Hollywood no I think it wasn't I got
a tweet this morning from Sarah
Silverman she was pretending that we
agreed on gun control which I don't
think there is a single point that we
agree on gun control she tweeted to me I
want to show this on the screen she said
wait I don't get it you think I care if
you legally have a gun or think cops
shouldn't have guns I can't imagine we
don't totally agree terrorists people
with mental disabilities domestic
abusers they shouldn't get done no kid
needs an ar-15 we agree no that was her
tweet to me and this is what I find
interesting been the last week or so
Democrats especially liberal celebrities
seem to have shifted their narrative
they are now pretending that their
policies won't deprive people of their
second Amendment right to bear arms but
if you look at the very March this
protests this rally that Jimmy Kimmel
was pushing from this stage of the
Oscars the things that they are
advocating for would deprive me a right
to bear arms no question there there's a
poll yesterday or a couple of days ago I
believe was from Gallup showing the 80
percent of Democrats said that they were
in favor of a full semi-automatic weapon
ban and about half of Democrats wanted a
full-on weapons ban for all towards
weapons including evolvers so for all
the people claiming the Second Amendment
rights are not in danger that we all
agree on this stuff III wish Sarah
Silverman would would answer the
question as to whether she actually
thinks that all so-called assault
weapons should be banned whether all
rifles should be banned in general
because they would answer pretty quickly
the question as to whether she's looking
for full gun confiscation